oh no what
no hi welcome
to christmas scary games all in
celebration
of the demonic entity known as santa
claus who is currently crawling down
your chimney
he's making his way across the living
room right now
he knows when you're sleeping
and he knows that right now you're awake
he's coming to find you he's coming up
the stairs
he's at your door
don't answer the knock
i hope you locked it
okay this is santa claus literally santa
claus i'm sure this is gonna be perfect
oh hey bud
okay bye bud oh jesus oh
what what
what okay if that's the music i'm just
gonna turn the music off okay that's
better
lixian put in the scary music eat a
cookie
i hope i needed to do that hey kiddo
we're gonna be out at our office
christmas party until
midnight your babysitter had to cancel
again but i know you're big enough to
stay home by yourself
remember make sure you turn all the
lights off and go to bed early and of
course
do not eat santa's cookies
[Music]
i did not think about i'm gonna eat the
candy canes
my god you
dick hole where am i
am i in santa sack good god
oh no what
no
holy crap sir jesus
hey santa uh i don't know how i got here
but could i go home can you open your
sack just a little bit
either your sack or your heart i didn't
mean to steal your cookies man
i really didn't mean to
you could taste my what you can taste my
rear
gosh santa you're too kinky for my taste
ah oh
that doesn't make any sense you were
behind me how in the hell santa what are
you doing to me
go away i don't want any of you i don't
what is happening to the floor
i'm never gonna make it out of here i'm
not good at mazes i i
i can't map them out i already have
forgotten where i am what i've been
oh please is that santa
is that santa
what was santa oh it's definitely santa
why did i stop and stare and look there
would have been no benefit to me
oh my fear oh that makes more sense look
is this all about the cookie
look my mom and dad they did not raise
me right they they left me
on christmas god that's sad i just
realized how sad that is
they left me on christmas crimbo
they left me on krembo all alone on
crimbo you know frankly i don't know if
i'm ever gonna get out of here
god i've never where in front of me
behind me in front of me behind me where
i don't know i'm never gonna make it out
of here
die ah you don't know that meanie
i'm just gonna try to follow the light
at least it's a landmark
hey bud
no please hey
i was trying to juke you damn yeah how'd
you appear in front of me you douche
don't be in front of me in the floor
okay i think this has got to be the
strategy oh
my god jesus girl
okay it's got to be this way oh how
how okay it's getting close again
[Laughter]
i think that's exactly where i died
before you still there
you're still there okay that that that's
like exactly where i died before
i think anyway how would i know i don't
know you behind me okay what if i keep
him behind me huh
why yeah i shouldn't look at him no
looking at him barely bad thing
okay you know what i'm just gonna go for
it screw it
oh okay good he's behind me oh i was
right
holy crap i was right i was right there
hey
give me give me give me give me give me
give me i get presents it's an elaborate
scheme
excellent not this year you got my
brother last year and my sister the year
before i get christmas
i love fortnite mom dad
i'm alive i didn't die
what kind of crazy workout room is this
mom dad
mama daddy mom and dad how many
bathrooms you need
mama mom dad
i win okay merry christmas that was
pretty good i never liked a maids
portion but you know even that one it
was good because it scared me so
had some good spooks pretty good pretty
good pretty good i like that i'll give
that a
seven out of ten eight out of ten maybe
pretty good
all right this is huston the house elf
you know huston
oh okay i'll take some music i don't
know why it was default
off i'll take it twas the night before
christmas we have all heard the story of
santa claus
but have you heard the one about the
house elf most homes have one and
certainly all farms have at least one
farm elf they are called host
and look like a small person often with
a long beard and pointy hat
they live in the barn under your floor
or in the attic and other nooks and
crannies the host
helps protect your home and tend to the
farm's animals as long as you remember
to put out snacks
however if you don't
bad things will happen instructions
wheel of snacks indicates favorite snack
collect snacks bring snacks to drop off
spots keep the house elf happy keep your
distance
survive until midnight i'm sorry
santa why are you giving me instructions
who are you to tell me what to do
i will be good or bad on my own terms
you fat [ __ ]
i'm sorry i apologize
okay let's do this wheel of snacks okay
great
i can't wait candy canes
okay 168 points
oh this hey how you doing
oh that meter's going down quick uh okay
um i gotta find candy cane and i gotta
put it
[Music]
what if i don't have it but what if i
don't have it
oh hello i literally
didn't find anything am i about to die
am i going to
am i dying what do you mean but i didn't
have anything
oh there it is okay
oh all right all right
i'm just supposed to collect anything oh
ah
[Music]
seems like there's plenty of food just
laying around you know they could just
go
get it why do they need me to get it
it's everywhere these stupid rats
you think that if they were gonna kill
me then they could just kill the rats
oink i did it i what is it wow
oh i have protection i put on a condom
my christmas condom i'm filled with
christmas cheer
is this a actual reality does this
actually happen in
real life are there house elves is this
real
how long do i have to do this oh my god
oh my god oh
what the hell is wrong with you
i got you so much food dude
hey linus johnson emma lindell pontius
mountiest
mila johnson as huston good job
man it looked great the thing
boy that was that was something else all
right moving on
okay this is chimney prowler am i the
chimney prowler
or is there a chimney prowler and it is
the night before christmas
and santa's a wreck how to live in a
world
so politically correct his workers no
longer would answer to elves
vertically challenged they were calling
themselves nothing that clamored or made
lots of noise
nothing for girls or just for the boys
nothing that claimed to be gender
specific
nothing that's warlike are non-pacific
santa grew weary of these tiresome moans
and made him quite angry i'll have you
know he tried to be merry
tried to be gay but you've got to be
careful with that word today
his sack was quite empty limped to the
ground
nothing fully acceptable was to be found
so two friends from across the seas who
met on the internet
wanted to see if they could catch santa
and fill him with glee
but little did they know they'd need
more than a tree
for santa was pissed pardoning his heart
entirely
i'm sorry hey aaron do you
think that we will like
actually see him no one's ever seen him
before
but tonight is the night
uh-huh yeah no one's ever seen santa put
together a radio tracker get a radio and
the
anthena the frick is the anthena
i hope you mean antenna i really hope
you mean antenna but okay
all right what is with this five nights
at freddy's ass place
what is this what a big freaking chimney
look at that that's a not a chimney
that's a chomny jeebs
all right okay all right so i gotta find
the antendu
this is just insane okay anyone seen an
an anthena
anyone got an anthena eyes on anthina
anybody i can't go upstairs anthena
anyone seen an anthena
okay oh that's the end i was looking for
a long stick
place the radio tracker all right where
am i gonna put it
back where i started probably oh yeah
there it is all right
cool point oh my equipment is up
how's it going up there yeah i'll get up
here
my god your roof is atrocious
i'm gonna go make the cookies now why
are you being so weird about that what
do you know about a dead bird on your
roof oh prepare a cookie for santa
oh my goodness what
what the hell was that
a damn shoe fell off okay aaron
we are 5 000 miles from landing
but there is this
weird interference weird interference
what do you mean strange very strange
what do you mean very strange what do
you mean very extreme what are you
talking about weird interference i don't
hear any interference
what are you talking about oh yeah one
cookie
i just piled a bunch of chocolate to
prepare special milk oh
okay all right special milk how much
booze we putting in this bad boy
oh yeah there we go that's the good
stuff a shooting star
wow oh wait no never mind
it's just a plane fifteen hundred
okay but that sound is
still there what do you mean it almost
sounds like
clapping what do you mean clapping
was the clap of santa's cheeks as he
makes his way downtown
down this enormous chimney how thick is
santa
hey my name is how dare you call me that
i would tell you a roof joke but it
might go over your head
yeah don't you have something to be
doing on that roof
oh yeah right right 50
you see anything fifty
you've got some interesting neighbors
fifty all i hear is the clap clap of
santa's cheeks
santa he's here
oh my god
[Music]
what are you talking about what the hell
is going up on this route is that
a cat
oh god no
it's santa
oh frick oh my god hi santa
the rude where are you
that clapping the clap it's in the house
now
what do you mean
i don't know what the hell this thing
up the is what are you talking about
what are you talking about where'd santa
go
what are you your ears are all broken
you're hearing cats
clapping of thick thick cheeks i don't
understand
santa thought my cookie was ugly which
is perfectly understandable because all
i did was pile chocolates on it
i hope you drank my special milk aaron
the clapping is getting louder what
clapping
oh god what do you mean
what it's the clap of santa's ass cheeks
oh no i was right all along i never
wanted to be right
i swear i didn't want to be right i
would give anything to be wrong
guys shut up shut up i
just i i'll let i just you know i can't
i don't know where santa went am i
supposed to hear him cause i don't
i really really don't i hear no clapping
of no cheeks i hear
nothing okay all right cool yeah hey
santa it's your favorite
child scruncho you know uh
can i get presents now oh oh
oh
oh god aaron
did he shove a christmas tree up his ass
everyone run run run run away
run away everybody as fast as you can
santa is gonna clap his cheeks all the
way until he finds you
he's gonna shove a christmas tree so far
up your ass
i just have to go find a car key there
it is
got it get to the i rudolph
oh my god i rudolph
[Applause]
please don't i guess that's marginally
better than the christmas trees anna but
please don't
my goodness i don't know man i don't
know
let me out of here where's the car
where's the oh that right right the car
i've seen the car before
i saw the car previously i know the car
oh i am driving
excuse me this
triple-a game oh aaa game
oh my god
let me just drive in a straight line
let's see what happens oh no i can't
wow that is a lot of britain okay i'm
gonna restart there's a lot of brake
lights
um wow this might be the greatest
game i've ever played in my life this is
incredible in every way this is stunning
oh it keeps
tricking me man listen to that engine
purr
oh four rudolphs that's a bit different
see that's
that's very different and also how can i
still hear the clap of santa's cheeks
even though he's on his sled i should be
hearing the cumulative clapping of all
the rain
i'm dead now and i'm back at the
my god this is impossible this is
awesome
this is the stupidest thing i've ever
seen god the momentum build up on this
thing
oh it's oh my god
oh my god i wanna die santa just please
shove the coal up inside me and just
you know just let me have it let me have
the tree i want the coal i want it all
give it to me i was for some reason
starting off from a dead stop there
trying to slow down okay slow down
you a-hole i've never had a car sequence
where
i i had to slow down this much okay here
we go here we go
we're starting to get it oh no no slow
slow my god slow down
slow easy does it easy does it oh
no oh well it's poor rudolph
oh my god 100 out of 100
perfect game never been a better game
incredible in every way
outstanding stunning beyond
good i will never have another
experience like that ever again in my
life
[Music]
i want a christmas tree up my ass moving
on
hello ho ho ho ho i am santa
i don't know if you have been naughty or
nice
but i wish you all a merry christmas
and a happy new year
i hate you i hate you bye
stop talking stop please never talk to
me again
oh hey
[Music]
what what
[Applause]
wait what wait what
oh this is how i'm what do i do
oh
i don't know what do i do story turtle
what
i behaved badly all here so santa will
punish me
we originally needed to correct our
mistakes so that it
ends who's we what demonic collective
enemies
are you a part of this did you do this
how dare you how dare you all of you
okay all right hold on okay hp i have hp
all right you know what oh great you
know what great
uh this is isn't this like this is the
house party house isn't it
which i imagine is just this way because
it's just like a default
house that's available in like an app
okay wash note
you need to collect nine gifts for
relatives and put them under a treat
okay take the dirty socks on cue and
take it to the washing machine
okay oh my god
what is this oh man
[Music]
hey oh good
oh good why am i doing this
how was this christmas
i can't read this
[Music]
centrality
go journal save password9238
okay
[Music]
oh wow that was very satisfying clunks
on that
i fixed up a notebook my personal
notebook with numbers
what numbers what numbers are in the
notebook
in the notebook what numbers are in the
and santa claus i'm just starting to
pass out everything's getting blurry
why is it blurry why is it blurry
oh my god what did i just do what
happens
the door is closed with a puzzle on the
wall
of course i hate this type of puzzle i'm
so bad at these
oh my god oh my god
hi
did i did it
[Music]
what take this sock santa
put it in the laundry i know put it in
the laundry
and the law and the laundry put it down
i can never i will never be able to
queue i forgot
q is the answer to that i'm stuck in the
door
queue he put in one
right exploded i don't know why
but it exploded
oh there's another one i'll take that
put it in freaking laundry
[Music]
hey
go away i'll take that carrot good for
my health
kaboom thank you
hey bud how you doing that listen uh no
busy here these didn't open before and
now they do and i'm
curious i would love it if the music
could
stop i would love it if the music would
stop i would
love the music oh boy here he comes oh
boy here he comes
how am i doing on i have carrots
i don't want to die it's very dark there
i won't go there without
luck we need to find a call without lock
you won't go there without luck
[Music]
friends note i have a note everything
quiet down please
you found anita notebook with addresses
and call your friends on the phone
i have one hello
[Music]
f
what did i say to who and why
hello hi
hey santa what is that oh another suck
can i have it please thank you i'll take
this
i wanted to explode it come home
[Music]
oh god why hey dick
hey stop it you're being kind of a rude
you're being rude what is that is that
turkey
snack note snack it's not a snack it's a
cook the chicken in the microwave for
the chicken
can i have it can i have this thank you
i'm just gonna pop it in the old macro
wow
microwave oh there we go
baby lob that on the table
that's the good stuff um speaking of the
good stuff can you leave me alone
oh my god oh my god this cannot get any
more insane i bet
but just wait it's about to
hey there's a thing hey there's a
present
got that all right save game yep you got
it
got that the door is closed you're
goddamn right it is
there's a present
oh a dirty si where did that i don't
know you know i i'm not gonna ask
what put blow it up blow it up blow it
up
that's not gonna blow hey bud how are
you doing
oh boy i don't know where i'm gonna find
a clovey
oh shoot oh shooty dude oh shooting my
toots
oh shooting my toots uh carrot
yes carrot yes carrot yes no and it
sounds like a soda can
i'm sorry i'm sorry i need
yes excuse me ah
yes holy [ __ ]
oh my god
holy crap
what the hell okay so i'm missing
just a couple more
hey it's a clover i can go up in the
bedroom now
[Music]
yeah i'm in here now
i made it and oh god hey
a-hole dinglebat
i just need to check aha four of
five well damn it
i'm gonna lose it i am losing it i've
lost it actually
the music is really getting to me i am
currently losing it there's a
some kind of an ornament around here
somewhere
stop no i'm stuck oh god oh god oh
please please please i don't want to
lose it now even though i have it saved
[Music]
what what what you blew okay he blew
okay let's see if in here there's gotta
be something right
oh that's the last present
i think that might have been the last
present hey bud hey you look sad
man you look sad boom probably cause i'm
about to do this
oh
i don't know if you have been naughty or
nice
but i wish
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
uh
all right so that was three scary games
the meaning of christmas told
as it needed to be told the kind of
christmas that we needed this year and i
appreciate it
hope you have a wonderful christmas hope
you have a wonderful holiday season
thank you all so much for watching
if you want more scary games let me know
down below
check out the description for even more
scary games that i have played in the
past
and as always i will see you
in the next video bye-bye